what are you doing I'm shaving the dog I
thought you were gonna fill out the
income tax return as soon as I shave the
dog well I don't understand you I just
don't understand you I mean the weeks
I've been begging you to shave that dog
and now when there's something important
to do that's the time you pick to save
the dog well I don't nag just be glad
I'm finally shaving him well I could
just scream April fit ain't is the
deadline the sooner you get your return
in this when you get any refund it might
be coming to honey I'm just as eager to
file as you are you only leave them half
shave that's the principle of the thing
you're just shaving that dog to
aggravate me honey do you want me to
shave him or don't you of course I want
you to shave it you know I want you to
shave it well then I don't understand
all right look if you're in such a hurry
you shave him I'll make out the tax
return well I really should start dinner
anyway doctor yeah just as we're coming
out of the tunnel yeah everyone in the
dream suddenly turns to me and says look
there goes Gertrude Ederle
uh-huh yeah yeah well I don't say
anything yeah and I give Goleta rain to
the elephant de haut because I want to
pay the Good Humor man for the popsicle
yeah sure yeah well suddenly Goldie
turns to me and she gets very up buddy
and she says if you can afford a
popsicle hold your own elephant he
wouldn't take the other no well what do
you make of that well I'm mrs. Van Loon
you know I see a pattern becoming clear
in all of your dreams and I think this
one it's unmistakable your unconscious
is telling you not to forget to file
your income tax return early you see
yeah yeah elephant becomes clear when
you remember the deadline is April 15 oh
yeah yeah well now I know what the good
you were man means oh yeah the sooner I
file my return the sooner I get any
refund I might have come here yeah
doctor can I deduct you from my income
tear off a tasteless don't mr. Danvers
miss Wilcox why won't people file their
income tax return early because
don't know because I think April 15th is
so far away is it my fault we begged
them every year we begged them the
sooner they file their return the sooner
they should receive any refund they may
have coming should I have to beg miss
Wilcox I'm a person young don't torture
you thought this way mr. Danvers I hope
particularly that they'd file early this
year because well it's my birthday did
you hear that it's his birthday
atencion atencion must finally be paid
to such a man thank you miss Wilcox
happy birthday mr. Danvers and forgive
me many happy returns